[Music]
there's no use denying it Riverdale has
quickly become one of the most
anticipated Netflix originals of the
year
fans pulled together to view the latest
season of the show and they were happy
to find out that it didn't disappoint
watch until the end to find out which
high school student is a lot older than
they appear to be first time at the
things don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and give this video a
big thumbs up now let's find out the
truth about our favorite Riverdale
actors what follow rules I make them and
when necessary I break them as all mugs
Chanin purser plays the role of Ethel
mugs a shy dorky and vindictive high
school student and while we love her in
stranger things and Ciara Burgess is a
loser
she doesn't give off the same type of
charm in Riverdale regardless of this
the 21 year old actress is blowing up
the scene watch out Veronica Lodge
because Ethel's got her eyes on you and
dear daddy dearest Polly Cooper 23 year
old actress Tierra Scobie plays The Cult
loving Polly Cooper and although she
doesn't appear in every single episode
she does leave an everlasting impression
Polly hates her parents for what they
put her through but she's one to forgive
those who've wronged her for now it
looks as though this teenage mom has a
hidden agenda cheryl blossom behind the
cool calm and not so collected character
cheryl blossom is the gorgeous actress
madeline pêche this fiery high school
student isn't one to bend under orders
which makes her both loved and feared at
24 years old madeline is quickly
climbing up hollywood flattered and we'd
love to see what she gets up to next
Reggie mantle Reggie mantle is a
complicated character and this is
because you never know whose side he's
on 27 year old Charles Milton is
responsible for playing this Riverdale
athlete but he wasn't always actor Ross
Butler was first cast as Reggie but
eventually left the role to Charles
which actor did you like best be sure to
let us know in the comments below
Fred Andrews actor Luke Perry is the man
behind Fred Andrews and he honestly
couldn't have found a better role for
himself at 52 years old
Archie's dad is always there for him but
he does have a knack for being targeted
by deranged criminals luckily for us
Riverdale fans Fred always
kicking Jughead Jones if there's one
character we can't get enough of its
Jughead Jones 26 year old child star
Cole Sprouse plays the role of this
literary genius and we wouldn't have it
any other way
the new Southside Serpent's leader isn't
one to mess around which is why his
fellow snakes respect him
Hyrum Lodge there's no use denying it
Hyrum Lodge is probably the biggest
villain in riverdale 47 year old Mark
Consuelos has become one with his
character and it's getting harder to
imagine him in a different light he's
continuously bumping heads with the law
as well as his daughter but he's not one
to back down Betty Cooper she might look
like a goody two-shoes but Betty Cooper
has a dark side like no other 22 year
old Lilly Reinhardt inhabits her role
like a woman on a mission and we can't
wait to see what her next move on
Riverdale is she's the brains of the
operation but she's as dangerous as a
loaded gun Veronica Lodge believe it or
not but actress Camilla Mendez had never
really acted before being cast as
Veronica Lodge the 24 year old embodies
her character like no other and we
wouldn't have her any other way she may
be young but she still got her career
ahead of her Hermione Lodge being
married to an ex-convict who just won't
let up is not an easy thing to do but
Marisol Nichols makes it look like it is
the 44 year old actress plays Hermione
Lodge on Riverdale and she's quickly
learning that there's no such thing as
divorce when you're married to a crime
lord tawny topaz tawny topaz might not
look a day over 16 years old but the
actress who plays her is 26 year old
Vanessa Morgan was the perfect choice
for Tony and we can't wait to see how
strong her relationship with Cheryl
becomes she's tiny and cute but she's as
tough as nails but hey she's a serpent
after all
Kevan Keller 26 year old Casey Cod is
the man behind kevin keller and we just
love him as the former sheriff's son
kevin has a knack for justice that most
people would overlook landing this role
was a big deal for Casey after all it's
one of his first big gigs miss Grundy 36
year-old Sarah hable might be a nice
person but she does play a disgusting
character while she was quickly killed
off the show the ex teacher promptly
left
mark after sleeping with many red-headed
students miss Grundy chose to switch
schools and focus our attention on a new
pool of underage students AFP Jones
whether you believe it or not Ski
Ullrich will soon be pushing 50 the
seasoned actor executed the role of FP
Jones perfectly and we hope he'll rejoin
the Riverdale production sometime soon
after beating his alcohol addiction FP
finally became the dad Jughead always
wanted Valerie brown 25 year old Hayley
love might not be a prominent figure in
Riverdale but she does pop in every once
in a while
her character Valerie Brown dated Archie
for a short amount of time in season 1
but quickly found out that he wasn't who
he pretended to be Hayley is currently
cast as Lizzie Elliot in the TV series
altered carbon Chik Chik might be the
most manipulative character in Riverdale
but that doesn't stop us from being in
awe of him 25 year old Hart Denton plays
the creepy and conniving character and
there isn't a doubt in our mind that
he's the best guy for the role we're
waiting for you to come out of hiding
chick so come out come out wherever you
are
Alice Cooper there are a few people as
hard as Alice Cooper which is why
directors had a hard time finding the
perfect actress for the role luckily for
them 47 year old Machin Amick blew them
away with her audition she's fierce and
ruthless and everything we wouldn't want
in a mother Archie Andrews you would
think that actor KJ app' was born with
red hair but he's actually a brunette
the 21 year old hails from New Zealand
but he manages to hide his accent like
it's no big deal
we couldn't picture anyone else filling
in Archie Andrews shoes and while he may
look older than his co-stars he's
surprisingly one of the youngest people
on the set
Josie McCoy you might be shocked to find
out that actress Ashley Murray is the
oldest Riverdale high school student on
set the 29 year old has the voice of an
angel hence why she's perfect for the
role of Josie McCoy while she may look
like a preteen she's a full-blown adult
so which Riverdale actor is your
all-time favorite make sure to let us
know in the comments below and if you
love this TV series as much as we do
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up and that's a wrap
thanks for tuning in and
you next time on the things
[Music]